l'ansej et quand on entend voilà on a
entendu florian philippot vallerand
cette très belle en tout cas merci non
franchement ça me fait du bien je n'aime
pas les objets
utiles non mais c'est vrai quand vous
entendez ça et il ya plein de gens moi
je vais me faire l'avocat du diable
aussi ce soir ya plein de gens aussi qui
disent on va se faire vacciner on nous
dit qu'il faut une troisième dose après
on va peut-être nous dira une quatrième
200 km2 est ce que vous comprenez aussi
un moment qui est des gens qui ont peur
moi je dis il ya plein de gens et pour
que ce n'est pas de la mauvaise volonté
va être ils ont peur ils savent pas trop
il se tâte et ces gens là c'est quand
même grave de l'edl et de mine de rien
aujourd'hui de les mettre à l'écart
parce que c'est des gens qui savent pas
trop et qui dès qu'ils attendent et
aujourd'hui ils ont l'impression qu'on
les pousse et qu'on leur dit allez c'est
parti va te faire vacciner votre faire
vacciner et voilà il flippe un peu moi
je comprends que des gens aient peur est
juste moins fort et expliquer les choses
et c'est pas à nous de le faire c'est au
médecin et il faut avoir confiance à la
communauté scientifique ils ont peur
parce qu'ils ont tout lu sur les réseaux
sociaux et ça je le comprends tout à
fait par contre ce qui revient pas que
sur les réseaux sociaux on a toujours
peur écouter ce que dit un gect canton
nous injecte un truc dans le corps on a
toujours peur alors une fois
excusez moi mais bon quand même relevé
est-ce que je peux relever de trois
incohérent gens sont rentrés de la cure
ce que moi mais on peut pas tout laisser
des à monsieur division lundi nous
expliquait qu'il voulait pas venir sur
le plateau parce que ils étaient ils
avaient peur d'être contaminés comme ont
été vaccinées qu'on n'avait pas fait de
tests enfin il a peut-être fait
aujourd'hui parce que il est un peu en
boucle mais quand il va sur les plateaux
il n'y a pas de pass and i turn et n'a
pas peur des autres
et non mais je fais un tir groupé dans
notre groupe et
non philippe audic zone family et tous
les jours et ensuite côtoyer dans la
zone ça lui fait pas peur d'être
contaminés attendre madame garrido qui
soi-disant défend la veuve et l'orphelin
pardon mais pensons au personnel
soignant quand on est d'extrême gauche
est soi disant pour les gens les plus
fragiles quand c'est eux qui bossent
épuisé depuis un an et demi votre
position n'est pas d'or avec
attentat donnait les répondantes iter
extrême simplement vous êtes juste à
bercy sur le diable c'est bon c'est bon
d'abord fabrice di vizio répondent ému
par madame je vais d'abord posé les
règles si vous voulez bien de ce débat
où ça se fasse
la gueule je le connais
logement
dal et ben moi j'ai nommé la raison il
abat sa saison voilà vous n'êtes pas non
mais vous n'êtes chanson appelée s'il
vous plaît merci pose pas les règles et
en norvège on peut vous laisser parler
si vous tuez ben allal soumises dès dvd
bon je suis désolé de vous avez rappelé
m laurence vous arrêtez national dont je
voulais bien se calmer deux minutes
qu'est ce qui vous pose ton problème
pour que vous soyez obligé d'être
hystérique à ce point je crois qu'elle
est amoureuse de vous
[Applaudissements]
on
n'est pas sur les autres insupportable
tenir lui avait posé une question j'ai
vous réponds oui moi effectivement ce
système du pass sanitaires je le trouve
complètement aberrant il ne sert à rien
maintenant il n'ya que deux façons de
voir le problème où il met pour personne
parce que personne n'est convaincu de
son utilité que son utilité n'existe pas
qu'il n'est pas fait pour lutter contre
l'épidémie et auquel cas alors il faut
l'abandonner part qu'il n'a aucune
utilité ou alors il a une utilité et il
faut le généraliser mais ce qui pose un
problème est que vous ne semblez pas
pouvoir percevoir temps vous êtes dans
l'idéologie madame c'est qu'en fait
actuellement votre pass sanitaire quand
vous regardez les chiffres effectivement
s'avère être une passoire sanitaires
pour reprendre l'expression de mon
voisin en ce que si les personnes
vaccinées peuvent continuer à
transmettre le virus alors je sais bien
que vous allez unanimement dire que
c'est pas vrai et que tout ça n'est que
du complotisme bien sûr car nous n'avons
plus d'arguments nous sommes obligés
alors d'avoir recours à l'anathème c'est
une technique d comme le monde mais la
réalité c'est que les 6/10 il a dit la
charge virale est la même la suisse l'a
dit je l'aide est mort six 6 10 il a dit
simplement effectivement la vérité c'est
que vous niez le réel à partir de là le
dialogue demeure impossible puisque des
séries de réelles mais je termine sur un
point pour répondre à gan moi si vous
voulez bien tout à l'heure ce qui me
perturbe monsieur moi si vous voulez
bien alors c'est moi accès wi max
pardonnez moi mais ça une paire alward
effectivement sur ce point c'est que
vous voyez mon c'est dommage parce que
comme eric naulleau je considère qu
effectivement vous est brillant et à ce
titre je ne suis pas sûr de bien
comprendre pourquoi est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas obligé immédiatement de
porter le débat sur le terrain de la
provocation
bien sûr que vous avez raison il y a eu
des excès çà et là dans les
manifestations ou ailleurs et vous avez
raison de les pointer mais est ce que
vous pensez monsieur moix que quand ce
qu'un journaliste dit qu'il faut emmener
les non-vaccinés entre deux gendarmes et
les pics et de force quand un médecin
dit qu'il faut sortir la boîte à claques
contre eux et non vaccinés quand
effectivement journalistes traitent de
connard les non-vaccinés nous ne sommes
pas dans l'excès monsieur max je ne vous
ai pas entendu dénoncer ces excellents
cécile sable et je l'aiderai gens et je
termine sur ce point de vue je sais vous
semblait effectivement avoir quelques
soucis est que notre présence non non
pas la vôtre vous avez vu c'est pas bien
a précisé que c'était pas le cas c'est
parce qu'il a dit il fabrique mais tout
ça pour dire que au fond vous voyez bien
que c'est le problème de ce débat
monsieur max et qu il sait hystériser
parce que finalement nous n'avons pas
vous avez vous souvenez de cette
expression peut-être monsieur max à
propos du sida lorsque nous avions pensé
trouver un traitement et que à la fin on
s'est planté il ya des expressions cas
de murray qui a traversé les siècles
c'est ce qui se passe pour le politique
mais cette main dans la culotte du
scientifique et bien c'est ce qui se
passe de nouveau nous avons le politique
a décidé de mettre sa maman accueillir
du sang du scientifique et de l'homme et
les médias s'ils sont aidés aussi à mes
l'année de crise à madonna
vous voyez c'est exactement ça le coeur
du problème c'est que nous avons fait de
ce débat un débat politique là où il
aurait dû demeurer un débat médicale
en fait un objet politique s'il vous
plaît aidez business woman ont décidé
madame j'attendais cet argument madame a
il a une fonction des conditions il
fallait absolument les nouveaux recours
au quotidien chat mais il fallait
absolument madame utiliser cet argument
vous n'en avez aucun autre à mon égard
plein d'autres messieurs alors allusif
aujourd'hui vincent sur jard
vous avez sorti une fake news
aujourd'hui sur une dépêche afp dia deux
ans en termes qu'on existe vous avez
donc vous avez sauté sur une cigogne ou
ce que vous avez fait relayer lui par
des milliers de personnes en laissant
penser que pfizer allait se réunir à
paris vous n'avez pas répondu deux
secondes s du niveau d'un avocat
monsieur fédérer seul le finir je
voudrais effectivement poursuivre et
bats ta valise il continuait à céder une
chose entre autres une chose à la vôtre
jean vilar décès en vendée des records
grévistes avaient même pas monsieur
puisque vous raconter n'importe quoi la
charge virale est moins importante en
fait dans mon rapport entre états dans
l'économie alors ils ont des arguments à
revendre dans la technique ici
vous voyez ce qui générera vous voyez
pas dans un débat technique a dit voyez
ci lui ce qui se passe ces manifs on
sait très intéressant voici que les
tenants du bien étonnant du respect qui
revendique le respect et bien c'est le
respect pour eux mais pour les autres il
y en a plus en fait car moi en fait je
suis accusé le propager des chèques news
effectivement j'ai relayé un article qui
était datée du mois d'août et je n'avais
pas connaissance qu'ils étaient faux
n'empêche que la réunion quand même eu
lieu et quelques années ce qui interroge
2 en deuxième point si vous voulez
deuxième point nous sommes quand même en
l'occurrence me parler business lorsque
nous payons deux millions d'euros par
mois un cabinet qui est à l'origine de
50 mille morts par an aux états unis sur
la crise des opioïdes je dire si vous
aviez un peu de culture et moins de
mépris madame et bien je vous assure que
nous pourrions dialoguer mais tant que
ce n'est pas le cas je préfère me taire